[Musique]
du violon du rock
de l'électro du dancehall et même de la
musique latine le tout dans une même
soirée et l'éclectisme ne s'arrête pas
là car lorsqu'un ondes c'est aussi un
restaurant un bar lounge et une
discothèque inauguré ce soir même
n'établissent pas accueille aussi un
public de tout âge
on se lance
aujourd'hui on ferait un établissement
comme celui ci pour vraiment prouver
qu'il est capable de faire de
l'événementiel en martinique en mettant
de côté la violence une inauguration des
espaces festifs qui ferait presque
figure d'exception
ces derniers mois plusieurs
établissements dû fermer leurs portes
le plus souvent suite à des faits de
violence au lamentin changement
d'ambiance la ferme perrine accueille
tous les jeudis kwaxicolor et ses
invités
sur scène lot 2 l'artiste dancehall
crise met le feu mais si ce soir tout va
bien l'entrepreneur de spectacles mais
qu'elle les toits a tout de même dû re
localiser ces soirées suite à la
fermeture en juin dernier du domaine de
l' oasis voit pas combattre la
délinquance en fermant des
établissements la préfecture après un
gros travail depuis quelques mois depuis
plusieurs mois en provoquant
régulièrement et c'est bon de faire
appel
aujourd'hui les organisateurs
d'événements décrivent un métier de plus
en plus difficile et compliqué en
réalité c'est et je pense je pense pour
l'ensemble des organisateurs sont un
véritable défi en fait et c'est parce
qu'un don de soi en fait d'organiser un
événement le people beach a ouvert ses
portes il y un an et demi maintenant
les nouveaux propriétaires ont investi
près de 300000 euros pour remettre à
neuf ces infrastructures d'un ancien
hôtel
ici on vient se détendre en sirotant des
cocktails autour de la piscine et a
beaucoup trop de violence ici mais
regardez comme on est là ici on n'a pas
la violence avec nous on est au calme
ici et à des années avant jusqu'à minuit
1h à 3h du matin on n'a pas ces
problèmes de violence et si
d'établissement se prête au farniente
il accueille aussi des événements
musicaux avec animation dj mais entre au
cahier des charges imposé par la loi
volonté politique et réalités du terrain
l'exercice peut s'avérer complexe
aujourd'hui c'est très très très très
réglementés quand on entend des gens qui
font des procès pour un bruit pour un
coq qui chante trop fort
à un moment donné on se dit on et en
sort d'où quand on sort des tambours
vous fait trop de bruit quand on fait le
carnaval c'est trop de bruit
un sentiment partagé par d'autres
professionnels du milieu
mais c'est compliqué pour lui parce que
il va pas il n'ira pas non plus en
prison on valide sonné pour faire quoi
c'est vrai que le cahier des charges n'a
rien à voir avec celui qu'on avait il ya
quelques années et plus on est au rec
moins 100 gagnent de l'argent puisque
effectivement il ya des normes qui
demande beaucoup d'argent et mais on
obligé de le faire
d'un côté la volonté de faire émerger
une culture de l'événementiel de l'autre
contexte social parfois peu favorable
une équation difficile qu'il faudra
nécessairement résoudre si l'on souhaite
voir se développer en martinique une
véritable économie du divertissement
[Musique]